beh
insomma
intanto
santana
un bacio parti
per tale
dio
un po
perché
beh
amori
nuova idea
si no
tanti
alto
martin
all
no
e allora
sì
all
vai vai
bari
urlare ce lo so che non sa fare non
è un dono
nel nome
frullare non solo
credono
bene
grazie
ecco
si no
no non solo
va bene
un amore
non so
bravo sberle
fino a otto anni fa
finco painting era nostro pivot
passaggio ad arte tutti noi quando i
proprie mani abbiamo iniziato a
avvicinare alla carta tavolo alla
pittura e quindi per noi c'è una
primordiale collegamento con il finger
painting la manualità
adesso finalmente neanche de giro vi ho
fatto una piccola dimostrazione
e qui un processo molto molto manuale
può anche essere molto tecnologico
grazie a questi nuovi interfaccia di
tablet smartphone che ci permettono con
i piccolissimi sensibilità dipingere
proprio come quando erano bambini io ho
iniziato il 2008 dipingere con l'iphone
ei è stato una rivelazione per me perché
ha potuto utilizzare una cosa molto
tecnici per fare le cose molto molto
tradizionale
noi dimentichiamo spesso come la
tecnologia e l'arte hanno sempre
viaggiato insieme ci sono tanti piccoli
sporchi segrete l'arte che forse non
parliamo tipo utilizzava si dice la
camera scura
lo sappiamo che canaletto non usarla e
techno dolci per noi è sempre stato
importante nei colori nel tecnica di
pittura
quindi io uso questi sono dei miei
quadri che sono prodotti di un mano una
vita digitalizzata che ci dà la
possibilità di creare animazioni e ti
posso dargli tornare indietro ci dà la
possibilità di interpretare l'arte in
auto lo maniera tingting per me è anche
store italiani
il poter raccontare le cose che mi sono
vicino al cuore le cose che mi passano
fra le teste e poterlo condividere con
voi
quindi io mi sento attraverso arte e
adesso di giro sangro paiting un grande
strumento di comunicazione il dialogo
molto molto bello per me questo è il
racconto di una pesce inventato robotico
che avrebbe potuto vivere in una scatola
50.000 anni fra adesso ha detto jean
rania in un mondo virtuale dove
l'abbondanza è infinita solo la
creatività poterebbe scarseggiare e
troppo vero noi non dobbiamo essere
vittime del delle tecnologie ma noi
dobbiamo utilizzarlo per liberare ciò
che abbiamo dentro nostro nostro
assoluto creatività abete arci dire che
noi abbiamo magico paolo già abbiamo
poteri magici
attraverso questi strumenti che abbiamo
un ideale possiamo comunicare con grande
facilità più più grande facilità che mai
nella storia 15 cia prevede bellissima
opportunità e spesso i ragazzi giovani e
non sanno che hanno tra le mani un
potenti strumenti di creazione outlook e
comunicazione io dico ok arte e
resilienza e la l'anima e tecnologie
resilienza per l'intelletto e abbiamo
bisogno di entrambi in questo quadro è
un'esplorazione la reazione fra
popoli non può quelli che hanno popoli
che non hanno popoli che stanno bene dai
popoli che stanno male e non
ognuno può leggere quello che vuole in
un quadro però di lasciare con questi
due pensieri migrazione e residenze
storiche e geopolitica e accoglienza e
resilienza del cuore
grazie moto